- I gotta meet this kid.
- [Woman’s voice:] Hello?
- Ms. Dobson?
- [Zenobia Dobson:] Yes, this is she.
- How you doin'? This is Carmelo Anthony.
I wanted to talk to you about your son.
- Zack? He's down at MTSU.
He's playin' football.
- That's what I hear.
I wanted to know if I could come down there and meet him one day.
- [Zenobia Dobson:] Let me call his coach to see if he can set it up.
- All right, well, I appreciate that.
Talk soon.
♪♪♪
- [Zack Dobson:] I still to this day,
I just don't understand, like, why everything happened.
Cuz, like, we was literally chillin'. Like, wasn't doin' nothin’.
- [Anthony:] Three years ago in Knoxville, Tennessee,
Zack Dobson and his brother Zaevion were just laughing on the porch.
Zae died. Zack ran.
He's tackling an all-too-familiar situation.
Movin' on from tragedy back home,
makin' moves to be a better player and a better man,
all with a smile on his face.
- [Zenobia:] This is Texas Avenue.
We’re comin’ up on the house that Zack, Zaevion and Markastin were raised up in.
Hey!
- [Markastin Taylor:] Twenty-one sixteen.
- [Zenobia:] Twenty-one sixteen—that’s it.
That’s where the boys were raised up at.
On the side of the house, that was the football field.
[Laughing]
- [Markastin:] Yup.
- [Zenobia:] That was their field.
- [Markastin:] That’s actually where the ground started.
- [Zenobia:] Hmm.
- [Markastin:] Zaevion would—he would push Zack to his limits.
- [Zenobia:] Hmm!
- [Markastin:] He would.
♪♪♪
- [Zack:] He was, like, my little big brother basically.
If I’m there, Zaevion’s there, or he’s not far.
It’s Zack and Zaevion always.
- [Zenobia:] I mean, ridin’ their bikes,
goin’ to the playground, goin’ to the basketball court.
- Well, I’m from the hood.
There was bad stuff goin’ on in the neighborhood, like shootings and everything.
But, I mean, we made a way to really, like, stay away from all that.
Like, we was just doin’ our own thing—in our own world.
It was the last day of school. It was break. Then we went to the Fulton game.
So we go home. I checked in with my mama. Checked in—everything was cool.
So we end up walkin’ on the back street all the way up this long street.
We got up there. We just, we just chillin’.
Then all of the sudden, we just see people walkin’ towards us in the street.
And then I get up, cuz, like, I know everybody in the community.
Like, everybody know me, my mama and my brother.
So I’m like, “OK, this ain’t, this ain’t about to happen.”
As soon as I took a step off the porch,
as soon as I—as soon as my foot touched the other step, they start shootin’.
That’s when I get to panicking. Just panicking.
And I, I just took off. I just took off runnin’. I just took off runnin’.
I just took off runnin’.
- A developing story in Knoxville
- Tennessee is mourning a high school football player.
- Sophomore standout who had star potential
- Who was killed by a group of gunmen.
- Randomly targeted in a shooting
- Shot dead.
- Zaevion’s story has dominated social media
- The teenager who’s being hailed a hero
- Died trying to shield three girls
- Three young girls
- In a spasm of violence
- [Screaming] Lord, I need you! Oh, have mercy!
- He wasn’t in the wrong place at the wrong time. He hadn’t made a bad decision.
He was exactly where any other kid would be.
Your kid. My kids.
He gave his life to save theirs.
An act of heroism a lot bigger than anything
we should ever expect from a 15-year-old.
- [Zack:] It was, it was everywhere. It was everywhere.
And, like, I would say, like, I didn’t really,
I didn’t really get to grieve how I really wanted to because, like, it was just so much.
Like, it was just the, the media and just how everything, how everything got, like—
It was just, I really didn’t get the time to really grieve.
♪♪♪
- [Rob Black:] The moment Zack stepped on our campus,
he was full of energy, very talented.
Not very large in stature but played so much bigger than he really was.
- Zaevion followed him the year after.
- [Jermaine Buchannon:] Just because he didn’t want to be Zack’s little brother,
he pushed to make a name for himself, and I think that pushed Zack to continue.
- [Black:] Zack was your skill guy.
Zaevion was more your bruiser linebacker-type guy.
You could see between his freshman and sophomore year,
he figured out that this is not youth ball.
- People think I got just good all of a sudden—nah,
I was really, like, workin’ out like crazy.
Like, I was doin’ footwork drills almost every night.
Like, go outside—4 in the morning, 3 in the morning,
don’t matter—doin’ footwork drills.
Be like, “You know what, I’m just gonna get this work.”
- They called their room “the locker room.”
It smelt like a locker room as well.
[Laughing]
Our house in Lonsdale? Like, we had the most company.
It was like an open home.
Like, she never had a problem with any of our friends coming over.
- [Zenobia:] It’s about love. I mean, that was my main thing.
- A team mom of all team moms.
I mean, she knew every player. They all knew her.
They felt very comfortable around her.
- [Zenobia:] If they didn’t have their grades, they couldn’t play ball.
If they didn’t have their homework, they couldn’t play ball.
-  [Buchannon:] It taught ‘em hard work.
- [Zack:] Here, run this. “Hit the fence,” that’s all he said. “Hit the fence.”
- [Buchannon:] And along with hard work, we won.
So that taught, along with hard work, comes success.
And I think you carry that with you through life.
- I know that the jury, they heard me. I’m his brother—I was firsthand.
I said: I’m not a gang member. I’m an athlete.
- [Anthony:] Zae died a hero, and Zack
had to learn how to go to school without his best friend.
How to play without his favorite teammate.
How to live without his brother.
And while Zack stood up to accept awards
in Zae’s honor, he was rebuilding a life of his own.
- [Zenobia:] He just felt responsible.
He thought that Zaevion was with him when he ran.
- [Black:] I remember Zack not bein’ able to come to school for a while.
I mean, it was affecting him in a, in a way that you would imagine it would.
- I’ll never forget this: My coaches came to my house.
- I felt like it was part of my job to go get him back here and try to support him.
What a strong young man, and I know where that comes from.
I know that comes from his mother.
- Every day was a struggle.
He didn’t wanna go to school. He didn’t wanna get outta bed.
[Sighing]
He had a mental breakdown.
- Like I—like, we did everything together, so he was always with me,
beside me, at breakfast with me, so I just, I was just not feelin’ it.
Just—depression. I just didn’t feel the same.
Like, I didn’t feel myself. I just felt dark. Just real dark.
- [Chaton Mobley]: There were times when he just used to test me.
Be like, “Bro, I don’t know what to do. I don’t know, I don’t know what’s next for me.”
He used to tell me how he used to stare, stare in his room, and nobody
used to be there, and he didn’t know how to handle
his brother not being there anymore—somebody he grew up with all his life.
- [Zenobia:] We were at a breaking point.
But that support and the love that we had for each other—we just
grabbed each other a little tighter...and held on.
He didn’t give up, even though he wanted to.
And he was at the point of his life where he could have.
He could have got revenge. He could have been bitter.
But he wanted to rep his brother in a different way.
- [Zack:] It was either the night or the next night that it happened—I, I texted
my coach, and I was like, “I wanna change my number. I wanna be 24.”
- “I wanna wear Zaevion’s number. I wanna be No. 24 next year.”
- He said, “Mama, I mean, I know that’s what Zaevion wanted.
I’m gonna live his legacy. I’m gonna do what it takes for my brother.”
- [Cheering]
- [Zack:] He wanted to be a coach. He wanted to be a coach.
That’s one thing—I will never forget that. He wanted to be a coach.
He would always tell me he wanted to pick my school.
I was gonna straight up let him pick it.
He was the football guru, so I’m just, I’m gonna let him do it. That’s you.
There’s one thing he’d say: “If a school offer you, they’re
gonna offer me too, cuz I’m your brother.”
- [Anthony:] Now Zack is out here at Middle Tennessee State University—
the first in his family on a college scholarship,
playing wide receiver,
wearing his brother’s number,
making a name for himself.
- [Coach Rick Stockstill:] I think the thing that, that stands out
the most about Zack is just his overall athleticism.
- [Zack] People still recruit small guys. I mean, if you can play ball, you can play ball.
- [Stockstill:] The ability to play multiple positions.
Because he played running back.
He played wide receiver. He played defensive back.
He returned kicks.
- [Mobley:] We never thought it would come true until senior year
when we realized that Middle Tennessee had both—recruited us both,
and they both liked us, really both as players.
Once they offered me, I knew they was gonna offer him eventually.
- [Markastin:] As soon as he got the news that he was goin’ to school, his,
his expressions and everything just changed, and then
you could just see the life just be put back into him.
- [Zack:] Once I got here, everything just kinda got back to normal.
- You know, he rides that dang skateboard.
- [Mobley:] He's a wild one. He rambunctious or not, he a good guy.
Real lighthearted.
- [Stockstill:] He fit in really fast, you know, in the locker room,
because of his outgoing personality.
- [Mobley:] Anything he can find to yell about, just to make
the atmosphere not dead, he does it.
- But he’s got a great attitude.
He comes to practice every day to work and get better.
And if he’ll keep doing that, then he’s got a chance
to contribute more and more as this season progresses.
- Look at your body.
You see that shoulder right there? That’s slowin’ you down.
You gotta turn and run.
You see that? All you gotta do is just run.
You’re faster than all these dudes.
OK? Just run.
- [Zack:] Before every game, though, I just go into a whole other mode.
I just think about, just everything that’s happened to me.
I just be like, “It’s time; it’s time to go.”
I haven’t scored yet, but when I do score,
I always point at the sky or throw my 24s up.
I’m still a dad, so—like, it’s a blessing really.
Just reborn again. Like, a new life is born.
My brother’s name is Zaevion William Dobson.
So I, I named him Zion William Dobson.
- [Anthony:] Zack is still showin’ out as the backflippin’, skateboardin’ life of the party.
But let’s be real: Zack is more than just a brother of a hero.
He is more than a boy who ran.
So I went to Middle Tennessee State to find him because
I wanted to remind them all: This is what Hoodie Season is.
- [Stockstill:] Are you a talker or you a doer?
Are you a man of action or are you a man of words?
We've got somebody to come in here and talk to you guys.
- [Crowd:] Oooh!
- Is that Melo?
- [Cheering]
- Oh s--t!
- [Zack:] What does Hoodie Melo mean to you?
- [Anthony:] It’s a mentality. So Hoodie Season for me is, is all about
how you’re able to just buckle down, lock in on what you gotta lock in on.
- [Unidentified coach:] Somebody or something in particular that you’re here for today?
- I came out here for Zack.
And the reason I came out here for Zack is because of his story, right?
And, and knowing what he’s been through and knowing,
kinda, what his family been through.
You’re still grindin’. You’re still pushin’.
You still rockin’. You’re still here playin’ football.
You coulda easily gave up, right?
You coulda easily fell victim to that mentality of “Yo, my brother is gone,” like.
Where your mind at is right now—that’s what I’m more interested in.
You know what I mean?
- I don’t try to put it past me, but I just—
- Right.
- try to put it in the back of my mind—don’t let it really distract me and get me.
I just keep goin’.
- Right.
- Just keep pushin’. Keep doin’ it for him.
Cuz then I got a son now so—
- Oh, so that’s—
- He’s like—I got, I got another reason to do it—for him as well.
- That’s almost like a blessing from a tragedy.
- Yeah.
-But you keep doing whatchu doing on the football field.
Cuz like I said in there, all that hard work paid off.
Like, everybody see how hard you work.
- I appreciate that, for real.
- Absolutely.
- It’s love.
- Of course.
- That s--t crazy.
- That conversation was more than just being an athlete.
What’s real is: This is not about basketball. It’s more than football.
It’s about you losing your brother, like, how do you respond to that?
Life is bigger than sports, but sports bring us together.
So when we give what we can to each other,
when we commit to each other,
when we struggle together,
we win together.
This is what real is.
- I’m just livin’ life. I’m just livin’ life.
Tryna make it.
- [Cheering]
- [Announcer:] Dobson, sweepin’ around.
Dobson, in the end zone!
The freshman scores for the first time in his career!
- [Zack:] When I do score, I just smile. It's Zaevion.
It's Zaevion. Every time.
Everybody comin’ up, “So you friends with Carmelo?!”
And I’m like, “Man, I did not know about this!”
They like, “Oh, you lyin’.”
“I’m serious! I didn’t know about it!”
They talkin’ ‘bout, “Who comin’ next?
Who comin’ next, Zack? Who comin’ next?”
They say, “Who next—LeBron? KD?”
He took time out of his day. Came to see me and talk to me.
And that’s, that’s love. That’s mad love.
- This is Carmelo Anthony. Thanks for watching.
To meet more heroes, go to breal.bleacherreport.com.